So today we're with Dr., Erika Rosenberg. And she's an expert in the psychology
of emotion and facial expression of emotion. So Erika, can you tell us
something about how you got into this field of study?
>> It's kind of interesting because it's not something I thought I would do when I
was a kid. That I would study facial expressions of emotion. But if you look at
my, my baby pictures, it might have predicted this. But, I was interested in
the effects of emotions on health. in, in general, I was interested in stress
and health, I went to the University of California San Francisco in their
Health Psychology program to get my PhD. After my first year, I met Paul Ekman
who was a professor there. And I found out he had really developed this field,
of the scientific study of facial expressions of emotions. So, that's how I
started working on it. I saw the face as a tool, to learn, to measure emotion.
>From a purely research point of view. But, once I got into it, it led to this
whole series of fascinating applications for studying the face.
>> Well, can you tell us something about, what was some of the groundbreaking work
that was done early on?
>> Right, right, right. I mean, it's interest in the face in studying emotion
actually goes pretty far back. It started in the nineteenth century when
Charles Darwin, published a book, you know, in 1872, called The Expressions of
the Emotions in Man and Animals. Where he, he had all these wonderful drawings,
and photographs, of animals, and humans. A lot of the pictures were of his
kids, making different emotions faces, and he was trying to make the argument
that there's fundamental about how emotion is shown. Not just in humans but in
a variety of animal species. That is, sort of inborn inate. And he had, he did
very informal research methods of having people all over the world send him
pictures from their journeys or drawings at the time, and saying, if you show
these pictures to people, do they recognize them as the same ones we do. And
his anecdotal evidence We're pretty consistent that there was a small set of
emotions that are conveyed with certain facial actions that's consistent for
all humans.
>> All over the world.
>> All over the world. And his research methods were not real precise. And in the
early 20th century, this idea of things being in born, was not very popular
because behaviorism was just getting going. And it took until The, the 1960s,
actually when Ekman and Friesen did their pioneering work. Not just to other
industrialized nations, because they'd found some agreement consistent with
Darwin's, in industrialized countries. But they decided, if you really want to
find out if something's innate, not learned, then you have to go to cultures
where they're not sharing the kind of information that we share in
industrialized nations. So he went with an anthropologist friend to Papua New
Guinea, which at that time, no longer, was a preliterate culture. They didn't
have exposure to any western films or whatever. And, Ekman and Friesen showed
members of two different tribes there, some of the photographs they'd used of
certain poses of facial expression of emotion, but most of those people were,
you know, European-American looking. So they also gathered photos from the New
Guineans themselves, and used a variety of different methodologies. And
surprised both Eckman because he didn't expect to find this, and the scientific
community that there were about five or six different emotions for which the
facial configurations were consistency recognized the same. Both in you know,
at the time, Eckman was in Berklely. Berkely, California. And of Papua New
Guinea. So that seemed to speak very powerfully to the idea that there were
universal facial expressions of emotions. But this was a small set. So, we're
talking about anger, fear, disgust, happiness, sadness and surprise, about six
emotions. To model these universal expressions, I'm going to need to take my
glasses off. Now the important thing to remember is that these are prototypes
so like any prototype this is sort of like a classic just like a, an apple's a
classic fruit and there's other fruits that are not you know as typical. This
is sort of the prototypical example of each of these emotions that I'm going to
show you. So I'll start with anger. Anger the brows are lowered, the upper
eyelid is lifted, the lower eyelid is tense, and the lips are pressed together.
So I can't talk while I do that so I'll do this. That's anger.
[LAUGH]
This is disgust. A key sign of disgust is the wrinkling of the nose. Fear.
Happiness. Sadness. And surprise. And this is an emotion that later work has
suggested is likely to be universal or at least has some good cross cultural
agreement, and that's the emotion of content. Which is the only of the set of
universals that is only, really, a unilateral or asymmetrical expression.
That's contempt. So. But contempt wasn't one of the emotions they used in the
early word.